Hey everybody is Charlie! You guys may
have heard about all the deleted scenes
that the producers were talking about
going into Game of Thrones Season 8
so I'll break them all down we also have
a bunch of new details about the unaired
secret pilot episode that they're never
allowing to be viewed by public eyes
that I'll break down - I'll just do all
the scenes top 10 style like I would do
a normal episode there's a new round of
the book giveaway - all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video starting with
number 10
Ser Pounce. The showrunners revealed what
they did was sir pants on the TV show
he's still alive in the books right now
as of Dance with Dragons but Dan and
Dave revealed that they killed Ser
Pounce off screen so this is their quote
Cersei hated the name Ser Pounce so much
she could not allow him to survive so
she came up with her most diabolical
execution sir pounces death was so
horrible we couldn't even put it on the
air they say if you buy the super
extended super duper charged Game of
Thrones box set that comes out later
this year the death of Sir pounds will
be in there they go on joking a lot
about it just a super episode devoted to
the death of serpents like they just
really hated that cat when they were
filming those episodes so that's the
main reason why there's no sir pounce on
the TV show people just wondering like
where a lot of characters like ghosts
For instance, where did Ghost go. So people
are naturally asking about ser pounce
and this was their answer we killed him
off off screen I think a lot of people
are mistakenly attributed her motives to
grief over what happened to Tommen and
the cat being a reminder of what
happened to Tommen but remember how much
Cersei hated Margery with a passion
Margaery Tyrell is the person that gave
stir pounce to Tommen to sort of win him
away from Cersei remember that was a big
arc during the books and on the TV show
but moving into the deleted scenes from
the unaired pilot there's actually a lot
of Easter eggs for stuff that's
happening during season 8 so they
really are paying off a lot of big arcs
but you remember that the original
unaired pilot they claimed is so bad
that they never wanted it to see the
light of day they recast a couple of the
actors like Daenerys and Catelyn Stark
were played by different people they
completely changed a lot of scenes and
changed a lot of characters
personalities so 9 after Ned Stark and
Robert Baratheon go to the crypts to
visit Liana's tomb in Robert Baratheon
leaves the exotic bird feather
remember the feather that showed up
during the season 8 teaser trailer and
during season 5 when salsa went down to
the Crips at Winterfell after she'd gone
back to Mary Ramsay Bolton there's a
scene in the unaired pilot after Ned
Stark and Robert Baratheon come back up
where Cersei goes down and I'll just
read the scene here long shot of Cersei
in profile wearing a heavy fur over her
elegant dress she stares into one of the
burial vaults the shadows about her
dance in the candle light Cersei exits
the crypts crosses the courtyard and
walks into the antechamber between the
kitchen in the Winterfell Great Hall
while the big celebration is happening
in the Kings arrivals underway she's
getting fixed up before she walks in and
sits at the great table and she looks at
a stark serving girl and says a word
with a stark girl
this handmaiden walks up and nods and
Cersei steps forward Cersei reaches into
her sleeve and pulls out the brilliantly
coloured bird's feather Robert had
placed on Liana's stone hand
Cersei hands the feather to her
handmaiden and says burned this they
probably changed this just so the Cersei
wasn't quite as aware of what Robert was
doing and leaving their relationship a
little bit more implicit number 8 when
Daenerys is getting married to Khal
Drogo they have a much more consensual
relationship from the start so if you
remember by the middle of the season in
the actual version of the episodes that
we saw they had sort of come to terms
and Daenerys felt a little more
confident and I think that was largely
more to enforce the arc of her adapting
to her environment like it starts out
really bad but she slowly acclimates
through the season and I think they were
just trying to give their relationship a
bigger arc than it would have had
originally had they started out with a
happier marriage number 7 when bran
catches Jaime and Cersei together in the
tower at Winterfell
it goes down way differently and it
completely changes the dynamic of Jaime
and Cersei relationship before he
catches them Cersei had told Jaime to
stop like she wanted to hit the brakes
on what they were doing part of the
reason I think they changed that is so
that later it would make more sense when
Jaime is the one who wants to leave
Cersei not the other way around
because in the original unaired palette
it seemed like Cersei wasn't really
happy with the twincest like it was a
more reluctant relationship for her
whereas in the final version of the show
that we saw she was 100% Jaime and grew
very upset at the idea that she was
being taken away like the moment that
she has with Brienne during season 4 at
the purple wedding like how dare you
ever think that
Jamie would love you so it makes more
sense for Jamie's Ark when he eventually
leaves her because that whole time she
had always wanted him number six the
opening scene with the White Walkers
goes down very differently they actually
speak to each other at great length the
scene went like this the crackling is
coming from multiple sources now these
are not the noises of mindless predators
this is a language and whatever is
speaking is getting closer then it goes
on will closes his eyes against the icy
voices beneath him muttering silent
prayers the person that created the
Dothraki language and the high Valyrian
languages for the show also created a
separate white Walker language called
Skroth it's right out of the books they
actually do speak to each other in the
books
it sounds like ice cracking the reason
why they got rid of that in the final
version is just because it made them
seem more mysterious and scarier if they
did not speak which is also why the
night King has never spoken in why he'll
probably never speak it'll be
interesting to see if they actually do
stick to their guns in the night King
does not say anything at all during
season 8 I know a lot of people are
wondering if that's going to happen number
five in the unaired pilot there's a very
different version of the Great Hall
banquet scene Jon Snow sits down at one
of the tables when the Far Away tables
with benjin gets drunk and they have
this comedic scene where he slips and
falls into a serving wench and she
spills all of her drinks and it's really
funny and he slinks out of the Great
Hall with ghosts behind him in the final
version of events he was not allowed to
sit in the Great Hall because Catelyn
felt like he was a bastard and didn't
belong there so it just emphasized his
role as feeling like an outsider which
informs his entire arc across the series
the original version of the scene though
where he gets drunk is in the books
though some of these scenes are book
scenes like the White Walkers talking so
some of the changes do make more
narrative sense for the arcs that the
characters have had on the TV show but
obviously some of them for more
practical reasons but then number four
also at the Great Hall banquet scene
when Ned Stark and Jamie have their
gunslinger standoff moment and Ned tells
him that he doesn't like to reveal his
skills before a fight it's just like a
sort of badass standoff moment between
the two of them in the original unaired
pilot they continue on back and forth
after Ned Stark calls him the Kingslayer
Jaime reminds him how the Mad King
killed his father and his brother
Rickard stark and Brandon Stark so the
tense moment just continues on and then
later after Ned Stark walks away Tyrion
drunkenly chimes in and says if it came
down to it I'd bet on you brother but
not much just sort of making fun of
Jaime and acknowledging how badass a
fighter Ned Stark actually is there also
was a flashback scene that they filmed
of the Mad King
killing Brandon stark and Rickard stark
that they had for the episode that
probably would have appeared when Jaime
referenced the moment when he was
talking to Ned Stark there were a couple
moments from that that they actually
included in the very first teaser for
Game of Thrones HBO has since pulled it
from the internet so it's really hard to
find but if you ever remember seeing an
original flashback scene that's what it
was from 3 like I said there were very
different actresses playing Daenerys and
Catelyn Stark and Catelyn Stark's
personality was very different in the
original version so originally Catelyn
Stark urged Ned Stark to accept Robert
Baratheon's terms to become hand of the
king and take the family down to King's
Landing and accept the betrothal of
Sansa to Joffrey so that Sansa could
become queen she really wanted Sansa to
become Queen when they reshot it in
recast Michelle Fairley in the final
version of the episode that we actually
saw Catelyn sort of tells off Robert
Baratheon to Ned Stark calling him a fat
man and she doesn't want to have
anything to do with the politics of
King's Landing she tells him to keep the
family in the north don't go so she's
much more shrewd in the final version of
the episode she also gets the letter
from Lysa about John Aaron's death and
initially in the unaired pilot she
blames Cersei in the Lannisters like she
thinks the Queen had something to do
with his death
in the final version of the episode she
just blames the Lannisters they probably
changed that in the final version of the
episode just because there were already
so many reasons for you to not like
Cersei like what was happening with bran
that they didn't want to pile too much
on her too quickly but number 2 also in
that original unaired pilot there's a
standoff between Robb Stark in Joffrey
really early on in Joffrey is way more
of an asshole right from the start
there's a scene where the master of arms
is training the stark children in
swordplay and they're fighting with
wooden swords in the field bran finishes
fighting Tommen in Joffrey sort of
snuffs at it and says tired of swatting
at Starks with play swords he suggests
they use a live steel in Roderick tells
him beat him with attorney blade then
Joffrey shrugs and starts to turn away
come
see me north boy once your balls thaw
laughter from the Lannister man Robb
loses his temper because he's talking to
Rob I'll cut yours off you little piece
of Theon seizes Rob's
arm to keep him away
from Joffrey it's as easy
Joffrey fan zeon turns to Tom and says
come on playtime is over
leave the children to their games this
gave him more of a reason to hate
Joffrey from the start and it also
tipped their hand as to Joffrey being
totally evil from the beginning whereas
the version of the show sort of ramped
up slowly and it was Sansa learning the
truth of what Joffrey was really like
because you had the death of Lady in
episode 2 and then slowly its Joffrey
getting worse and worse and worse from
her perspective but then number one even
though this doesn't seem like a big
moment it's actually a really big
personality change for Ned Stark so back
when Ned Stark and Robert Baratheon are
in the crypts at Winterfell they're
getting ready to walk out Robert says
don't keep me waiting too long it's a
bloody mess down there talking about
King's Landing you know what they say
the King sh*ts in the original entered
pilot Robert walks up the stairs leaving
Ned standing amidst the stark dead and
Ned Stark finishes the line in the hand
wipes what the show did is if they gave
that line of dialogue to Jaime later in
Episode 3 it was used as more of a
cutting remark against Ned Stark instead
of Ned Stark telling a joke himself
because it just sounds weird that Ned
Stark would ever tell a single joke in
his life he does have a sense of humor
like when he and Robert are having that
standoff moment he sort of smiles a
little bit that's Ned Stark if you heard
him start telling a bunch of jokes you
would think that he'd been possessed by
something but let me know in the
comments what your favorite deleted
scene and if there any other deleted
scene videos that you guys want me to do
for Game of Thrones let me know in the
comments there's going to be a lot more of
these on the season 8 blu-ray when they
released that later this year so of
course whenever that stuff comes I'll do
videos for it but that'll be after all
the regular episodes air congratulations
to the giveaway winner from my last big
Game of Thrones video August err please
email me on the about page of my channel
so we can get your contact details click
here for my big Game of Thrones season 8
episode 1 preview video and click here
for all my other Game of Thrones season
8 trailer videos and promos thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight!